لوهله اعتقد سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
ان الحرب ابتعدت عنهم لاشهر كانت سماء
العاصمه هادئه لا يعكر صفوها ضجيج الحرب
المستعره في الجنوب والشرق لكن اسراب
الطائرات المسيره غيرت هذا الواقع في وقت
وجيز 60 طائره مسيره هجمت العاصمه خلال
يوم واحد في هجوم هو الاكبر من نوعه بحسب
عمده المدينه كما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان
روسيا هاجمت المقاطعات الجنوبيه من
زبروجيا ودينيبرو شرقا الى اوديسا غربا
مرورا بميكولايف وخرص وسط البلاد بمختلف
انواع الاسلحه من غارات جويه وقذائف
صاروخيه اما على جبهه بخموت فتتحدث هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه عن صد 50 هجوم صاروخيا
واتهمت موسكو باستعمال القذائف الحارقه
وماده الفوسفور الابيض المحرمه دوليا
باخمه التي تستمر المحاولات الروسيه
للسيطره عليها رغم ما يبدو من وانتقادات
للجيش الروسي من قوات فاجنر اما في خاركيف
فاعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه استعمال
قاذفات استراتيجيه لقصف من قالت انهم
مرتزقه اجانب كما قالت انها دمرت مجموعتين
اوكرانيتين في مقاطعه كوبيانسك ومع اشتداد
القصف الروسي واستهداف كبرى المدن
الاوكرانيه يخشى المسؤولون في كييف ان
الاسوء لم يحدث بعد حيث تتداول على اعلى
المستويات في كيف انباء عن هجمات اشد
ستستهدف اوكرانيا بالتزامن مع ذكرى النصر
على النازيه التي تحتفل بها روسيا في
التاسع من مايو ايار
لا نعرف لماذا تشن كل هذه الهجمات الضخمه
في شهر مايو ومن الصعب للغايه تحليل سلوك
العدو وان كان لا يمكننا التاكد من الهدف
الذي وجهت اليه الطائرات بدون طيار الا
اننا نفترض انه من الممكن ان تكون مراكز
صنع القرار من بين تلك الاهداف حيث انهم
صرحوا مرارا وتكرارا انه بعد الضربات على
البنيه التحتيه ستكون مراكز صنع القرار هي
الهدف وفي بيان اللافت تحدث الجيش
الاوكراني عن انسحاب قيادات روسيه من مقر
وادارات يسيطرون عليها في خرسون باتجاه
شبه جزيره القرم واضاف البيان ان القوات
الاوكرانيه رصدت انسحابا مماثل في مدن
ومناطق خاضعه للسيطره الروسيه في المقاطعه
الجنوبيه